không à Vì A Sáng sáng nay tự nhiên sáng
nay tôi quay lại được đúng cho rất nghĩa
là 8 giờ sáng tự nhiên dậy để mà chuẩn
bị lên công ty làm làm tận 5 giờ chiều
mới về ngày hôm nay rất là mệt như là
vừa nãy ngủ ngủ pháp đến bé thì được gần
gần đến giờ dạy học thì bắt đầu rồi được
thì nên ăn vội
trong là thực ra đấy không khả năng biến
lịch sinh hoạt nó ổn lắm nhưng mà chắc
là thôi sẽ cải thiện dần dần sau ít nhất
là ăn là ngủ đúng giờ dậy đúng giờ Cái
đấy phải cải thiện đã
ok thì à
ừ ừ
à Hôm nay thì các bạn thấy thương đề đó
thì và mình cũng có thông báo đó là thứ
năm thứ bảy mình mình Bây giờ mình sẽ là
chỗ chấm qua nhóm đồ ăn không ạ Chứ
không không kiểu dạng là để các bạn kiểu
bạn kiểu phải từ từ thoải mãi không đúng
trào quà kiểu để các bạn chơi vơi rồi
Thế các bạn đang không biết được mình
đang làm đúng làm sai Vân thì mình sẽ
kiểu tôi cá cái hồi mà mình đi học đấy
thôi mình đi học mà làm đồ ăn ấy ngày
nào thì cũng kiểm tra ngày nào cũng lên
lớp cô Đời
em ngồi là mình sẽ ngồi làm trên lớp chứ
Đưa nhân vẫn ngồi ở nhà làm thôi chú ý à
vẫn vẫn phải lên lớp thì ngồi làm đôi
khi là cả hai cả buổi hôm đấy Thời chẳng
dậy Cái gì cả mang tiếng là mình đến lớp
nào chẳng dậy cả và thầy chỉ kiểm tra
qua Đôi khi thấy cũng không kiểm tra lần
như là mình sẽ ngồi ở đấy mà làm cũng
cái bạn là bạn cùng nhóm kiểu kiểu thế
thôi hết buồn thì mình đi về thì thế đôi
khi ở nhiều lúc nhiều anh em việc thì
tôi lại lười vì nhóm tôi mang tới gọi là
nhóm người mình tôi làm nên thành ra
kiểu
đến lớp hơi khó chịu bởi vì nhiều lúc
mình thức đêm mà cứ lúc mình thức đêm
ngồi làm cho tự nhiên sáng em xong mình
ở phải lên sớm đến lớp để điểm danh cái
thứ xong rồi Thầy Mất Tích
thì tôi trên này có cho mất tích thế này
ở thành ra là anh ra làm mấy ông thấy đó
tôi không muốn để cái ạ à
em không có để tình trạng kiểu mất tích
giống như thầy tôi nữa nhé Mà thấy tôi
làm mất tích kiểu này hay nó chỉ ở để
cho sinh viên tự giác học các thứ thứ
chủ yếu vẫn tự giác mà
Ừ nhưng mà tôi thì không thôi thì lại
quen dạy theo kiểu quá cái kiểu kèn kèn
từng linh tí này hi vọng ạ với ông vẫn
phải tự giác không thì không biết được
làm lần nó ạ ạ
ừ ừ
bạn nữ bạn nữ kia là bạn nào
chú ý không Bạn nữ kia bạn à à
à à
ờ
ờ 23 tháng 7 có phải cập nhật thêm Cần
Thêm cái vụ tao à
vẫn còn là thiếu quá
anh chưa có gì cả
đi xe đạp lạnh gel cập như thế nào bỏ
qua đi em tiếp theo tiếp theo là
a đấy à
à à
ở nhóm nào mà hôm nay muốn mình chữa
mình chấm Cái gì
nhóm nào hôm nay muốn mình chữa chấm gì
thì bình luận nhé
một cái tính năng biếu cụ thể hoặc là có
thể chữa tính năng thôi không cần phải
chữa cho nhóm của bạn đấy
không cần lấy cốt nhóm bạn đấy mà chữa
tính năng khiếu cụ thể Từ thể chữa cho
này hoặc là chấm nhóm bạn ấy tùy vào sửa
cầu em làm thế này ngon lắm rồi thế mà
mỗi lần chấm mà thấy cái bỏ qua
Ừ nhưng mà để tính năng nhá bảo tôi
chứng đao diện với tôi không Không Nào
Đó
ờ ờ
hác chị gái dùng vết cốc à Có một sự
thật này Bây giờ mày ông ấy cho làm nhá
Thôi bây mình tâm sự nhé thỉnh thoảng
Tâm sự tí cho không khí bớt căng thẳng
thì cũng như sự thật đó là à Ơ quen mặt
đấy
Ừ mai cũng có có tính mai ở điểm là nếu
mà nếu mà tôi mà học cùng trường bạn đấy
chắc chắn là tôi sẽ không được quen bạn
ơi và à không nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm tôi
học cùng trường mà Đấy chắc chắn là tôi
sẽ qua ở đây nhưng với góc nhìn khác bạn
ấy sẽ không ở quên tôi không ở bên tôi
hoàn hảo là cũng không bao giờ không
được có ý định gì cả thì tại sao như thế
bởi vì à
Ô kìa tôi nhớ là tao bằng tuổi thứ hai
là ở bạn đấy là hot girl ở trường đấy
Tôi không nói cụ thể trường nói phát đây
anh em biết cho dù có vài ngay biết biết
ông ngoài đồng thì cậu sẽ biết thôi nhé
người bạn nào rồi
Bạn ấy giỏi làm ở công ty nữa rồi giờ
làm cộng tác viên thôi nhưng mà cũng
giữa công ty to có thứ hai nói chúng sơ
yếu lý lịch Mọi thứ đều rất rồi và bạn
ấy tiếp xúc cũng rất rất nhiều anh em
dân công nghệ rồi nên ảnh ra ạ và học
bởi chúng Công nghệ cấy nha rồi thực
thực tế nếu mình lấy cái mác dân công
nghệ ra để mà để mà kiểu lấy lại các bạn
đấy khỏe mẹ gì bạn thấy chẳng có cửa thì
luôn đấy nhớ mà tôi lại có cái mác khác
đó tôi nhất là
bạn này vẫn còn đang ở trên trường Nên
lúc đấy tôi đi làm giảng viên thôi Ngày
thứ nhất thứ hai là tôi cậy thì em mới
gọi là
hai vợ chồng Gương mặt triển vọng ở
trường khác thì nó sẽ ổn hơn với kiểu
Gương mặt triển vọng của Chính trường
thì bạn ấy vì bạn ấy đủ nổi Thằng Trường
bạn ấy rồi lại sẽ không để ý mấy anh
cũng trường đâu anh cả đấy Nói chung là
gần như là chú
Ừ chú kiểu ở Nếu mà muốn tán bạn nào thì
em về cơ bản tán bạn khác trường dễ hơn
8 mạnh công trường
Anh
bảo vệ thử em cúp
Ừ thứ Bảy nè không không không Thứ bảy
này rồi rồi tôi rồi sang Nga ngày 13 gì
vậy đúng không nhỉ Có nhờ tôi rồi Tôi
nhớ tôi rồi rồi Tôi thông báo ở trên
discord mà
lùi lại ngày 13 rồi
cho Nokia
nhóm mấy ông có nhiều nhóm đến bây giờ
mới làm xong đây bây giờ mới làm xong
tính nam đăng nhập này tôi chưa biết
được mình nó mới sẽ bảo vệ cái gì thực
tế nhá đó là gần như là đây là một cái
đồ ăn của mấy ông thì mới không phải tự
Dã là ngày nào phải ngồi cốt ngày nào
phải để cốt lấy ông nhìn này cách mà
không để cốt này Hôm nay đầy này rồi tí
tận ngoài hôm trước đây tít tận vài hôm
trước có có hẳn cận Hằng 2 tuần không
làm này chả thôi Chả làm thế này cả mấy
ông đi làm đồ ăn mấy ông làm cực kiểu
này á nếu không hãy coi nói nếu mà giả
sử Nếu em coi nó đương nhiên là nhiều
ông có bận không nói gì tôi không thể mà
ép mấy ông kiểu ngày nào cũng thúc được
như ý rồi à Nếu mà Mấy ông làm cậu thật
sự là tập trung vào nó thật sự tập trung
mà nó chỉ cắm đầu tập trung mà nó đúng
không Thì cần Như à hai tháng hai tháng
là gần như là mấy ông đã phải làm gần
như xong hết tính năng cơ bản các tính
năng nâng cao đã bắt đầu làm rồi mày
không ạ Đấy đúng ạ Chứ không có chuyện
là cậu
một tuần đẩy lên một vài năm cốt để rồi
ông ạ Nếu thực sự người Ông tập trung
vào thì đáng lẽ là ngày nào mày không
phải để cốc lên đấy đúng ạ Nếu ông hãy
coi cái này cái cái việc này nó thứ nhất
là đồ này nó rất là khó nhưng mà để mà
để nếu làm quen với việc cái sự áp lực
khi mà đi làm ngồi ổng Thế đi làm Ngày
nào ông cũng làm đúng không còn ngày nào
cũng đầy Cốt nó không khác gì cả ông làm
xong đồ án này để máu đi làm à đúng ạ
Nên là ông ông phải quen được với các
nước này không phải quen giờ ngày nào
ngồi cốt không ạ Ông phải dành thời gian
nó nó một ngày phải một buổi Chúng hỏi
nửa buổi không là một tiếng mà một người
một buổi để ngồi làm để quen dần Nếu
thực sự ông muốn theo ngành này thì đúng
ạ Ngày nào phải dành ở tuổi là ít nhất
là như thế để ngồi cốt bởi vì cốt Bây
giờ ông ngồi cốt thực tế là ông rồi Cô
chỉ có ví dụ có bốn tiếng một buổi đó
ông ạ thì một tiếng ngồi Quốc hội 3
tiếng còn lại ông ngồi sửa cốc rồi Mà
lại cần như kiểu
ông ông cốt vẫn còn rất là lo nó phải
thực hành nhiều hơn và Vân thì ông cố
trong vòng 23 Hàng thế
không có gì bạn cứ inbox mình qua
discord là bạn Bạn muốn làm để bạn muốn
làm đồ án đề tài gì và Vân muốn mình
chữa như nào thì inbox qua đấy rồi mình
sẽ mình mình sẽ cẩu ấy thì mình sẽ chữa
dọn chấm dần nó bạn bạn cứ làm mình đau
thắc mắc vì hỏi mình sẽ chữa lên lấy
cũng không có đương nhiên là khi bảo vệ
bạn sẽ bảo vệ một mình bạn là một mình
với một mình thôi vì bây giờ cũng lẻ thì
em cũng cũng không cầu nhõm chẳng có
khái niệm mở lại cái gì cả chuyến giản
là là bạn à Bạn làm sau ngồi mình chấm
thế thôi ông ạ Có nhiều bạn bây giờ đang
thế mà Bởi vì mấy Bạn học sau mà bạn cứ
làm rồi mình mình bạn có nhắn tin cho
mình kiểu gì mình cũng sẽ trả lời nếu
không sẽ biết được là nửa đêm tôi còn
non bao giờ sáng giờ vẫn sẽ trả lời với
ông ở con người không Nó bị kiểu cũng
năng nổ như tính quái nhiều lúc nhiều
lúc nhiều lúc đến chính tôi tội cảm thấy
ở trong tôi nói chuyện đúng kiểu như đa
cấp
bởi vì có đấy thì mấy ông thấy đây một
người không 37 nghe nó cứ cởi bị đi điều
ấy chỗ ở Xin chào người bình thường Ai
lại làm thế nào đấy đúng khả năng nổi
như tính thế cái việc là chẳng thu tiền
chẳng chẳng đòi đòi hỏi lại một cái gì
với ông nữa khi sẽ thấy sai sai Anh gửi
hình thật có vài ông từng nói đến vai
Ông bảo tôi à Anh có thu tiền đi Có khi
em còn thấy yên tâm hơn rồi
kiểu bị buồn cười như thế Ngon thế là
tôi hồi trước tôi quan điểm một cái ở
rất đơn giản thôi
Ừ thôi Cho tôi đọc một cái cái nó là Và
nó có câu rất hay đó là kiến thức để làm
toà nó phải nên miễn phí tất cả mọi
người
và chính xác là có một cái kênh YouTube
Gần đây tôi có xem có một người đề xuất
mà tệ và nó khẩu hiệu luôn nó glasskote
này
Ở
đây Ờ
tại đây Chúng tôi tin rằng à giáo dục có
chất lượng và chất lượng cao video giáo
dục có chất lượng cao nên đây nên Kiều
về tự thả kiểu cầu cần Như là nên nói
chung nhà có thể đặt cái gì sẵn giả dùng
hơi thô nghỉ ở chỗ nào có thể cho mọi
người miễn phí kiểu kiểu thế này ngon
đấy ngay câu đầu tiên nói như thế rồi
cái A Ừ cái này thì nói Tín nhớ cái này
dậy với 3 thứ không phải vì lỗi lập
trình đâu Tôi chả biết cái dạy lập trình
hay không nhưng cái này gần đây tớ xem
nó dậy về cả lịch sử và cái này toàn có
cả các chuyên gia xác nhận nữa Thế nên
là cái thông tin nó nó thực tế chứ không
chứ không phải là kiểu
kiểu dạng là cậu nói câu dạy miễn phí
cho vui rồi cũng dạy con nhà
Ừ anh em à đại khái thì thì tôi là như
thế em chuyện đó tôi thì con điểm khác
đó là kiến thức là để chia sẻ ảnh hưởng
thứ
tính triết học hay mà
tốt nhưng mà nhưng mà chủ yếu vẫn là tự
học này chả có có có người kiểu có người
tiểu học học cùng ấy
nhìn giống như kiểu tôi mất vào ấy
Ừ Chắc không sao đâu
Ừ thì có người học cùng thì mình sẽ cảm
thấy thoải mái em mình gặp học tốt hơn
tôi nghĩ thế
a
complete rồi con nít rồi
Ừ để tôi chữa cho nhóm này xem qua nhóm
này rồi tôi chữa đau tao bay trong tháng
7 nhá Giờ có bạn bảo tao những bệnh mà
đúng không
a one shot
nó động từ tên hàm thì nên đặt nó động
từ tên biến thì không nên làm náo động
từ ờ cái biến thì nên nó danh từ anh cần
như thế ế
mấy ông làm cốc rồi thì không đập đi làm
lại không ạ Cứ kệ thôi cứ phải nhớ thôi
kệ thôi
Ừ ok Đây là kiểu Nếu nó dịch ra sẽ nhạc
Một nhà cung cấp giống cửa sắt leo một
cái gì đó
Anh chưa hình dung được PR bạn này đặt
tên nó là gì lắm
Xin chào Này Xô viết này
ở đây
ờ ờ Spider dịch vụ nhà cung cấp đúng
không
Where này
nhỉ Đặt lịch này ạ ạ
ừ ừ
chị
Ngọc đi part special phố Vinh Này
bạn này Làm làm thế này Hôm trước tôi
không biết là tôi từng nhận xét nhóm này
chưa Nhưng mà ngó mày hình như là tôi
từng nhận xét rồi mà nhà không nhắn này
bị khoe như này Chết chết mất quay ở nhà
nó sẽ bị rất là nặng
chị bị nặng mà bạn này đang làm theo cậu
là không phải em muốn đẩy đẩy dữ liệu
vào trong cái thằng này nhưng mà nhưng
mà bạn làm theo kiểu không dùng gossip
Mà bạn làm cái cầu ngày nặng quá không
ai làm cái này cả Không có năm nay cả
thế này nhá thì sẽ tạm cái video xin
sheet như này
ừ ừ
à à ơ
cái thằng này phố Vinh không thì mình sẽ
mình sẽ cầm lấy một hàng thôi mình sẽ là
à Đặt tên thành phố Vinh như thế này
ạ sau đó mình nuitơn I sơ đồ logic has
Won ngoại
đấy luôn ạ
nhưng mà cái này
anh bình tĩnh nha có tận 2 phố vi này
tôi xem
hope in
a vival mini nhà đi
nếu bạn tất cả hai cột nha Ok nó hai cột
thằng này sẽ là đi Battle Open điểm đi
điểm đến tỉnh Nhi tính đến Không ạ là
như này Đấy Xong rồi nhá nghĩa là mình
đoạn này mình sẽ xử lý sẽ query à
khi
quen này này đúng trước à
Ừ Rồi mình sẽ có quýt ở đây nữa
anh sẽ quyết Ở đây có
một vị sĩ luôn này à
đi pasle đúng không sau đó thì bạn muốn
kể tên của nó thôi bạn muốn lấy cái tên
của nó như thế này thôi đúng không ạ thì
mình sẽ là mình có thể lấy mỗi cốt phải
lên ngay đấy chỉ muốn lấy nên nó đúng
chứ
ở cốt điểm gì cốt là để mà mình phải cái
cái cốt để mình nối nói đến hai thằng
này phải thông qua Nối hai hàng ngày
phải thông qua cột mà nên kiểu gì Những
phải lấy cốt để nối sau đó thì bạn muốn
đẩy thêm bạn muốn lấy thêm cái À
cái poppin Devil Vân đối ngoại giờ sẽ là
như thế này
a map như này thằng trình ngay bộ phim
sẽ lấy từng hàng một mình sẽ có
cho ca nó ngắn hơn rồi xem xem nhé
khi
scandal gọi đến Viettel này sẽ bằng
scandal gọi đến Survival vin
lấy nên
nó như này
với cái á với cái à
a career in sheet Tôi sẽ đặt tên nó khác
đi như thế này
ở đây sao
sẽ là gọi đến kiểu đúng kiểu như này
em copy này mình sẽ existen Đôla
xe zip gọi đến hàng ngày như này Đấy sau
đó thì
Ừ Ok mình sẽ Open vào như thế này luôn
này
tình scarred yêu nha mình sẽ Open cái
vival
lên này và
a Mobile Game này là như này
rồi mình sẽ ăn xét cái thằng scandal
Nếu Giả sử bạn muốn không muốn lấy thằng
này ra ngay
và cả thằng hai nữa là sửa bạn muốn
Ừ cái mất lệ như nào cho nhanh nhưng tôi
thích chiều Để như này Tại sao vì sao
mình thích thêm cũng được tùy bạn mất
lên nó đỡ khó chịu gửi thông báo phải
chịu được đấy lại tức là làm này tức là
sao nghĩa là bạn không muốn là kiểu lúc
lúc mà mình quýt như này là nó sẽ tự
động
thì nó sẽ tự động kiểu à chèn thêm cái
đoạn vistlip và cho bạn Nếu bạn không
muốn thế bạn muốn cậu à
a pic cho đài đúng không
bạn Bạn muốn không muốn hiển thị luôn cả
đi ship thì sẽ ăn xét ở nữa đi Nhưng mà
trước đấy bạn vẫn phải lấy từ về toàn bộ
mày cái relationship này mình sẽ lấy
được tên của từng khám đóng ngoặc rồi
chuyền vào
ở level time này mình sẽ lấy từ
cho mát
thì tại sao phải làm cái loại Phức tạp
nhỉ
Ê mày Tức là gì
số Viettel tháng tôi chưa biết được bạn
này làm dạo này để làm gì Con đấy ạ
anh em viết bôi trách vỏ CV dự án chung
là cửa hàng sách thôi có gì review chung
với các project các bạn được không ạ
Được em em cứ inbox anh qua resort nhớ
anh có phải duyệt qua cái đồ án của em
xem nó xem nó phải cần sửa cái gì nữa
đúng không Ông bảo tôi review mà nó học
thì tôi chắc chắn là tôi sẽ phải họ để
sửa Nếu mà bây giờ bạn bạn là cần tôi
muốn review qua luôn cũng được càng tốt
không ạ Thế là mấy ông kia có vẻ đang
không cần review thì ông cần review thì
ăn tốt
anh nhá Cái này là tốt đây à
à À tôi hiểu rồi Hôm nay làm kiểu này
làm như thế nào nhỉ bài thơ ca nó làm
hơi sai đấy Cái đoạn này hơi xa này
cái đoạn này là bạn ấy đang muốn là lấy
thời gian là ví dụ tôi từ đây như này nó
là lấy thời gian
ở thời gian tới
a chia cho
là
1.440 là cái gì nhỉ
chưa biết lắm
là số phút trong một ngày đúng không Thế
thì
nếu mạnh mừng tính ở khẩu đi hết bao
nhiêu ngày lịch sử thế khi phải lấy thời
gian đến - thời gian
thời gian bắt đầu khởi hành đi nghỉ ông
làm sai rồi và lãnh cả là có hàm để tính
thời gian chứ không phải ông ngồi chưa
chia nhau ở đâu Ông muốn đổi ra phút ông
muốn đổi lâu dài có hàm hết
ông phải quy ước đầu tiên phải quy ước
nữa nó có thích tật nhớ ai
testament sông sẽ quy ước là là Kiều cái
ở thời gian của ông dù ở trong trường
hợp này nó à đi fatime này nó là cái gì
nó Nó kiểu dữ liệu là gì nó chết ham
đúng không và thằng travel time này nó
biết sao đúng không nếu khai báo kiểu
như này thì nó đã Song Riders nó nó tự
động biến nó thành đối tượng thời gian
rồi và lúc đấy ông muốn hiển thị nó ra
số phút hai cái gì đó thì đấy à Đấy ông
muốn đã giả sử dã sử nhé cái đoạn này
sửa lại Nó sẽ chuyển như thế này
nó đơn giản lắm Ông đã làm lọ này nó bị
phức tạp thôi là sự như này ông muốn chị
đổi pho mát ra hàng kiểu đâu cốt của ông
cũng như đúng không ạ ở đây nó còn có ý
hát
như này xong
Cô gái nghe xong rồi
à à
lô tô bay đi nhở sao
Ừ cái này cái gọi đây á em thêm trước
quay đi đây là sẽ gợi ý ra thôi à à
cả hai ông sẽ sửa lại được không mát này
nhá Mấy cái chỗ nào cũng sẽ trở lại nha
làm sai rồi sao chắc rồi cái đoạn này
chắc chắn thay luôn cái đoạn này nếu tôi
đang hiểu thì sẽ lấy thời gian của thời
gian đến - thời gian đi Nó xảy ra tổng
cộng mình đi hết bao lâu đúng nhất đấy
Đấy do mà tôi cần mấy ông phải phải gọi
Mít cho tôi để tôi xác thực xe mà mỗi
nhóm đang làm đến đâu có khi là tuần sau
phải ép buộc vụ đấy rồi chứ kiểu này thì
đây tôi sẽ cố trong mấy ông ấy Ông còn
đang không ngon tôi không thì tôi cũng
không biết được là thực sự ở tôi đang
chạy đúng hay sai cho nói đúng ý tưởng
của mấy ông ấy không kết hợp được cả tôi
nói xong thì thì mấy ông có thể đái Nói
chung hoa có thể đang không chú ý cái gì
gió lại bỏ qua đoạn này thì nó lại bằng
không sẽ có giao dùng đấy đâu rồi rồi
nhìn cô trò này trong sợ hoa
ở nhóm này chắc chắn là tôi sẽ phải
Duyên à
ở nhóm mày à nhóm 4
Nghe nhạc sàn
Ừ cái này tôi không nói việc ở đương
nhiên mày ông mới học gia thì đương
nhiên là không không thực sự cốt chuyên
nghiệp bạn này sẽ chắn rồi nhưng
Hồ Cốc đang bị rối và tôi không hình
dung được ý tưởng của ông thì
ý thì cái này lỗi của ông chứ không phải
là là liên quan đến việc là ông mời cốt
gì đó được chứ Cái này là ông nói cốt
Nhìn chồng nó nhằm nhiều rồi ngay
iz65 Mỹ chắc chắn nó kiểu gì chính bản
thân ông cũng thấy ở cái đoạn này nhằm
nghệ thuật thì cần phải sửa đúng không
Sao tự nhiên tôi đây này chưa có Buồn
cười quá Tôi thấy trong cốt buồn cười
quá
vợ chồng là đương nhiên là mới học thì
cốc món ăn nhậu nhưng mà bây giờ tôi
đang cần cái thích hãy nhớ nhé hướng của
tôi không cái mục đích của cái đồ này đó
là để ông làm được cái dự án ok rồi
nhưng mà cũng để cho mấy ông
đang đang từ fraxel bây giờ mày ông nào
fexo Nếu không biết cốt rồi Mày không
biết Quốc TP rồi thì vẫn chỉ tính nhập
facial rồi biết cả reo nhưng mà gọi là
mới biện chưa thực sự là không biết
cotell thì cũng được Tính và vẽ sơ thôi
Tôi đang hướng đến trong khi ông biến
thành Junior luôn Shino hơi quá Nhưng mà
biến hình Junior luôn luôn
cho tôi bảo sao Nghĩa là còn như là tôi
đang thuốc mấy ông để mà cốt sao cho
chuẩn Ít ra là chuẩn chuyên nghiệp theo
kiểu là biết cách tổ chức cốt không
không nói việc hiểu biết tất cả hàm
haswell hay là kiểu có chuyên nghiệp
thẳng được biển anh xin mất rồi nhưng mà
đang ngồi đã biết cách làm việc chuyên
nghiệp biết cách đặt tên đủ thứ để nó là
một Junior và lúc đi làm không ai nói
cho mấy ông cái điều đấy cả ông sẽ phải
tự học ở đấy thì sẽ sẽ rất dễ là tôi đã
từng đôi từng là nhưng mà đi ra là tôi
may mắn có người giúp còn mấy ông thì
tôi không tin là mấy ông may mắn được
nghỉ thế nên là tôi đang hướng là ông đã
ngay tự học ở nhà thì ông phải phải cậu
phải chuyên nghiệp ngay từ vụ đấy rồi
chứ lúc đi làm thì em không có người
nhắc ông ấy cái vụ là cốt của ông đang
như thế nào đâu thực tế như thế Tôi quen
vài bạn bây giờ đang đi làm ba bốn năm
rồi cố taller cốc cả codemasters code cả
Facebook khác cột vẫn như một trò đùa
bởi vì à Không ai chỉ với bạn đấy cả Và
thậm chí thậm chí có cả chúng yêu có cả
Suneo đi trước bạn ấy cốt của mấy người
này vẫn rất rối cốt người ấy Kiểu mình
cố tình khen hay chẳng ai chỉ mấy người
đấy nói hàng này như thế Không hiểu tại
sao người ta vẫn được cho là siro theo
cấu cốt Vẫn kiểu ra là lỡ lời
anh khó tối ưu khó nhỉ Xong rồi không
biết dùng bia truyền thịt không biết
dùng mình cái hàng thì cư ngực đầy nóng
nhưng mới nha Đặt tên biến thì vẫn chứa
nhiều lúc là tên là tên y cái gì đó
không phải abc nó hơi quá đáng nhưng mà
đặt tên là bata thằng Hiếu nó ta là cái
gì cả anh tưởng như thế
Chúng tôi khẳng định được là số lấy
không phải là ít rồi đâu mà nói
Em hãy nhớ thế Hãy nên nhớ khái niệm mà
tôi từng phân biệt bằng mấy ông ngồi
trước nó có khái niệm giữa developer là
nhà phát triển và và cố tơ là người biết
cốt cô đơn sẽ chỉ sẽ chỉ mãi là cu đơ
Nếu không chịu học hỏi thêm nghĩa là sao
ngồi gõ lại toàn bộ những cái gì đã biết
và không không đọc thêm tài liệu không
xem thế nào là tối ưu thế nào biết cốt
chuẩn hơn không không đọc những cái đấy
ngày ngày vẫn đi làm như ngày này chỉ
làm lại những thứ mình đã biết thì trình
sẽ không trở lên ngoặc họ làm tầm vài
năm Tâm Tấm 755 thì được gọi và gắn mác
sciglio gì không Họ vẫn chưa cu đơ thôi
nghĩa là họ vẫn chỉ làm lại những cái
thứ Họ đã biết đúng chứ họ không tìm
hiểu thêm Họ không làm được cải thiện
thêm gì cả cốt của họ sẽ chậm Học kệ họ
có người làm xong thì thôi đấy Tôi không
muốn mấy ông trở thành như thế
Ừ đúng chứ nếu mà thực sự là hãy nên nhớ
làm mấy ông theo cái em heo cái đồ ăn
Thứ hai này là phải xác định là theo
ngành lập trình rồi thì tôi sẽ dạy khác
phải đồ ăn một là tôi sẽ có cái sự khắc
nghiệt hơn nó sẽ có cặp áp lực hơn và nó
sẽ có phải chuyên nghiệp hơn chứ không
phải giống kêu đồ ăn một được
mấy hôm nay bạn này chưa nhỉ Sao tự
nhiên tôi đang ngồi mắt một lúc tự nhiên
lên view Cao đây rồi
ờ ờ thi nhớ mẹ không hiểu Tôi không Cái
này chắc chả là nhóm này
Ừ hi vọng mày không nghe được tôi tắt
luôn không mày
mái
vi
phạm cả nhóm sắp xếp một buổi
ừ ừ
Thi đặt tên ý thì cách đọc tên nó sẽ là
nó sẽ là kiểu ví dụ dạng nhưng mà Mấy
ông thức ra mấy ông thường nên thấy tôi
cố thì cách tôi là tên rồi nữa đó là số
nhiều hình để thêm chữ s này nên là tên
tiếng Anh này đấy các bạn để gạch nhựa
được nhưng mà theo chuẩn của pp Mới đây
tôi hơi khó chịu vụ đầy tí đó là nên kéo
đặt theo kiểu con lạc đà nhưng mà nhưng
mà đúng hơi khó chịu bởi vì đôi khi mình
kiểu copy từ tên cột Sang nó sẽ dễ hơn
đấy à
ông đâu rồi thì tôi hồi trước khi thích
nghe thấy tôi mắng thôi thì tôi mắng
liên tục ngồi đây luôn mà thầy Tuấn thấy
có phương châm thôi tôi từng kể với ông
ấy nhở nó phương phương châm là để cho
cả lớp ngoan thì đôi khi chúng ta phải
gì chết mua tốt đấy Tôi từng nói Tôi là
không tốt đấy Thì cư cho dù con tố đẩy
chưa Đán đến số phải chết đâu nhưng mà
thấy có gì chết bằng được một đứa để
xong mày được để làm We mấy đứa kia để
mấy đứa kia sẽ ở mình kia ạ Mấy đứa kia
học với tôi luôn là con tốt đấy thầy cứ
gì Thôi ngồi đấy được cả tôi không ở đây
ngồi đấy thôi mặt đã cho rồi thành ra
kiểu thấy gì Đương nhiên buồn thì có
nhưng mà tao vẫn cho cày tiếp nhiều
người khóc tựa như người bỏ đấy
xe Huế Hải Duy kinh cực tôi khá nhiều
lớp đúng không nhiều người thấy cứ gì
thôi Kiểu tôi làm được nhiều đồ án tôi
gần xong thấy vẫn gì kiểu Thầy cứ nói
rồi bạn à em cố tình này có hướng cho dù
mấy đứa kia nó còn cốc kẻ bên mình ở Huế
nhưng thầy không nói gì cả Vẫn khích lệ
bọn nó như cứ đến mình ở thấy cái gì cả
rồi Cả lớp thì cứ nhìn thấy cậu với
thằng kia giỏi thế mà cũng bị dính
tiền thầy không bằng trực tiếp nói gì nó
cũng sợ rồi thì hãy cứ gì Chết kiểu như
thế nhưng mà dí cái đấy kinh nghiệm thực
tế khi em mấy ông về sau đây làm quản lý
nhé Em hãy nhớ ông phải biết gì Đúng
người cái gì là đứa nào mà bật lại được
không Rồi còn nhớ là ông xong đấy không
phải gì để Nam mà hiền hiền hiền thì
chắc chắn nó không bật lại được mình
mình dễ gì nó cho nó gần như chết thảm
kiểu thế mà chị thoi thóp rồi đấy
Ừ thì thì thì lớp ở xảy ra cái tập thể
nó sẽ sợ âm gửi hết
ở hà tội không khuyến khích các phương
pháp này lắm nhưng mà
cái này không phải lính mới mình mới nhá
Đừng nhầm đình mới nhá định tính mới mấy
thằng lính cũ sợ cái gì mẹ thằng Linh
cũng nghĩ là do nó lính mới khác để
không phải gì cái thằng lính lính kiểu
cứu ông gì Chết thằng lính kỳ cựu đấy nó
rảnh nha thằng đấy con chết thì thì mình
làm sao sống được bây giờ phải như thế
chứ
trình nó là là đặt tên biến xong rồi
cách như nào thôi cứ ra vì sao Còn nhiều
cái nữa
anh hỏi chút rồi thôi quên nhóm này tạm
tạm tính sau nha
ờ ờ chữa database 577
mỗi Tài liệu tách nhé Nhóm 7A
anh ngắm vậy đã ra đây là gì nhé
Ừ ok
a database
ta có
này vợ muốn cậu
Ừ tôi cũng không nhớ được cả hồi trước
rồi à chữa máy âm như nào ở đâu khi muốn
đắp đi làm lại nó còn nhanh hơn
xem này bạn chắc là nhóm này Hồi đấy tôi
nhớ là Ờ nó sẽ có nó là chuyến ta thường
xuyên
một cách thường xuyên ở đây là nó cố
đích nào khoảng thời gian và nó sẽ có đi
từ tỉnh này sang tỉnh khác và mình hỗ
trợ là đi xe tương tỉnh thì vậy nhớ rồi
ý
nghĩa là sao cái tương tình ở đây là
khái niệm ví dụ là đi từ Hà Nội đến Hải
Phòng nhưng mà đi qua một tỉnh nào đó
chắc ạ Thì mình vẫn có thể nhận khách và
trả khách về đúng cách đúng cái tỉnh nữa
thôi là thôi cứ nói là Hà Nội Hồ Chí
Minh do nhiều không ạ xong rồi đi qua Hà
Nội đến Hồ Chí Minh mà đi qua với vụ ở
tỉnh tỉnh gì gì đó ở giữa ví dụ Giả sử
thế Huế Giả sử gia xử thế thì mình có
thể hoàn toàn thể cho khách xuống ở chỗ
Huế chẳng hạn thế hình như thế vậy anh
xem nha tự nhiên có
Kali cái này là gì nữa à Đây là
đúng không
á quân sự tên cái này rồi listen read là
cái bằng lái xe mà không
đấy nó sao hôm nay đúng
Ê mày hack rồi hôm nay Facebook YouTube
để cho tôi YouTube cho tôi lại Bây giờ
thì mở quảng cáo lên rồi Đúng
chính thủ xe bớt xe mà nhỉ
Ừ để da không hiểu lắm
mà tại sao có cái này thì tôi đọc có vẻ
ra xe thế cái bớt này nó xem à
em xong đồ án này mình đem bán được
không được nhưng quan trọng là ông có
đảm bảo việc là đòn ông chắc là ryder
khó bị hack rồi nhưng mà lo nhất được về
tính năng rất hữu thứ ông phải có một sự
cam kết nữa ông tôi không muốn ông bán
đi xong rồi đổ ông đỡ lo không có mất
tích tiểu đưa người ra đâu thì thực cái
đồ này nó vẫn
Ừ nó nó nó nó vẫn còn chưa hoàn thiện
đấy à Còn thiếu sót nhiều ấy ông có thể
em lấy kiến thức này để mông 8 hẳn cái
đồ ăn mới Ông Đập đi làm lại đồ ăn mới
vì đón này của ông tôi khẳng định là chả
có đồ án nào của các bạn bây giờ đang
hoàn thiện kìa Kiểu gì nó đang có cái gì
đó Sai sai
Tại sao sau này
từ kết quả này tự nhiên hình đấy
a radio
nhỉ
tự nhiên có pin đấy có giá này có
từ đi làm là điểm đi đến đây đến tỉnh
thành giống như vậy tôi nói này khoảng
cách cả khoảng cách thì
Ừ cách mình nhập và cũng được cũng được
Ừ nhưng mà Khoảng Cách này rất là mình
đang bị đi về toàn Nó hơi xa quá
Những Kẻ Thừa Kế thực ra ấy thì thôi
cũng được không sao
có nhập tạm vào được nha à
hình ảnh à
Ừ ok ok ok đem lại không ạ
nó lại khái niệm khác chứng phổ biến và
phải dựa theo hóa đơn của em mình sẽ đề
xuất chuyển phổ biến của cái pin em
chuyển ra anh muốn ghi mà lại thôi cũng
được đừng nặng ghi mà lại để mà mình sẽ
mình mình muốn nó luôn thì chị lên nó
Giả sử ta cái cái chuyện đấy mình cảm
thấy à là
nó cái điểm nổi bật nhất của bên mình
nản mình muốn nổi lên
ai chả thế
về giá
a dò dò Tôi đã nhìn cái này ở nhà nó hơi
bị cho tao quá Đợi tí thôi Nhìn cái nhìn
cái A
số sổ chức thể cho nó sẽ dễ hiểu hơn sâu
thể bay đâu nhỉ
từ đầu này nhỉ
Ừ
cái này cái này để vẽ lại sơ đồ thì mình
hình dung mà là bầy chứ
hình giúp nhá Ờ
vì nó có tỉnh này
số báo danh
ở tỉnh này
a City
Tải game Air Blade để điểm đó này thành
phố này rồi đi từ thành phố này đến
thành phố nào này
điểm đón này đúng không
Hôm nay không đi tập thể
đoạn này cũng say rồi City ở ông đồ
Atlas
A Bad Day I
A
Boss Boss này cũng là chuyến đi Nóng sai
này mình sẽ có
thì xe này
xe xe
về bản chất xe của ông sẽ có đi à
mắt xanh của ông đi đến nhiều địa điểm
nó chỉ có Tôn Đản thế thôi Nói là cái
City nữa City sẽ hoàng trung gian xe của
ông đi đến nhiều
nghe nhịp à nó bảo nhà một xe
Ừ đúng ạ Ừ
chuyến đi
à Tôi đang đi hơi bị loạn Dạo này đi
khi gà bởi vì nhóm này đang làm bài toán
nó rất là rộng giờ khó mình anh là kiểu
Thành An nó kiểu bị khó khó lên ý rồi ta
bài toán này có thể đơn giản hơn nhiều
nếu mà thực tế đúng là nó có thể khó như
này thực tế nó sẽ khó ngày thật nó kiểu
có chia chưa nhỏ ra như thế này
anh hả Ừ nếu mày ông bị loạn thì tôi có
thể chỉ cho bé Ông làm cái có dễ hơn
khi đóng thuế về cái đoạn này quá tải mà
không làm được đơn giản nhé
các bạn này thực tế nó sẽ khó như thế
này
không ạ
ngồi làm nó bây giờ không kịp khi làm
bài toán đơn giản hơn đi ngồi sửa lại nó
bê đơn giản hơn đi tính sau A
Ừ cái chỉ quan tâm mình nha
từ bỏ địa điểm đón đi này
ở đây tôi Tôi đang nói rằng cho giảm và
phải toán nhá một địa điểm đón đi này
Ừ anh sẽ chỉ có City này à
em bỏ distiny này bỏ hình ảnh đấy Ờ
ở đây sẽ có là từng cái
thời gian đó giá đi từ Đi từ
chuyến đi sẽ ra
Em hãy sao thầy hai này tách ra nhỉ
nghĩa là cùng cái điểm đi từ đây đây nó
giờ xuất phát khác nhau
sẽ lụp bụp lại với nhau thì nó sẽ dễ hơn
em bỏ ngon cần anh đi được
những ngày tiếp mày
chú bò này à
a nhớ làm đơn giản là một chuyến đi chỉ
có
11 giờ cố định đi thôi thì nó sẽ dễ này
anh
một giờ cố định
Đang làm hai cậu lại một ngày có thể đi
nhiều chuyến Nhưng mà giờ không những
cái cái giờ bắt đầu nó khác nhau
ở lại thế thôi bỏ được mấy cái này bài
toán nó sẽ đỡ dễ hơn rất nhiều rồi để
xem nhé hóa đơn này nó đơn
mình sẽ có
ở Tây Ninh status này có xe đi ey đi con
tê tê giác con tê tê đây nhỉ a file
Mở hộp này mình sẽ có
ở Mộc Hóa đơn
nó sẽ chỉ có cậu à bàn chất là bản chất
là cái á
số kế hoạch hóa đơn này bạn đang làm là
một hóa đơn có thể đặt nhiều xe đúng
không nhớ Bây giờ trễ chỉ có một hóa đơn
lập một xe và có quantity thế thôi và
còn cũng có đặt một xe sẽ là một hóa đơn
sẽ có bớt xe đi này và à
anh là gì nhỉ và
a customer đi này
à mà
các tệp file xong rồi payments
Ừ thì mình mới thế đó thôi đừng là phức
tạp nữa chỉ có sao tớ thôi và
onette là đặt bao nhiêu vé thì thôi
Ừ ừ thế thôi nó sẽ dễ hơn rất nhiều
Em email có thử thưa chuyển đồ thôi kệ
Ok sửa lại như thấy đào tạo bay của ông
trong sẽ giờ cơ bản để dễ có làm cái cả
tao tao bay của kia thì đến nơi nhóm ông
Nguyễn chưa thống nhất thì định bao lâu
người ta đồng ban đầu và làm đồ án nha
anh ngắm mày ok chưa nhỉ
Ừ cái cái bài toán ở đây à là mình cũng
đã tính tương đối để mà có thể một xe
thì đập đi được nhiều nơi rồi thực tế
thực tế nhé
Ẩm Thực tế tôi thấy còn Ví dụ ở Việt Nam
thì tôi từng đi xe khách vài nơi ở và
khẳng định là nó còn chẳng nó còn chẳng
khó nó chẳng thiết kế ra bên ngoài bởi
vì nó không làm mấy cái như này cũng
nhập bằng bay hết Nó không có làm kiểu
tao bay chia lỗ phức tạp ngay đâu Khanh
đẩy thế luôn đấy Và thậm chí là nó còn
trẻ tao bay kiểu nó nó nó kiểu parabay
có nhiều lắm kìa nó chỉ rồi nó nó có
đăng cái lịch trình lên thôi Nó không có
kiểu xử lý kiểu nó nhập hết bằng tay từ
cái location City đủ mọi kiểu giá các
thứ nó qua chẳng có thanh toán qua ra
đấy Chẳng thế Đúng nhỉ xem thử nhé
cài đặt xe buýt này à
à à
cho các loại xe khách chứ nhỉ xe khách
không có đâu
toàn kiểu
khi
chọn bừa nhá nhập này đi nha
bộ phim Chiến ơi
khi nãy nó sẽ đề xuất ra những cái bên
này nó làm gì
ờ ờ đây ok rồi này xem giá này rồi bắt
đầu rồi Kết thúc Ok này sẽ
nhà thuốc chặn ở đâu Dạo này có vẻ ổn
này
sự nó có ghi cụ thể location đâu
anh đúng không ở đây locations locations
Ừ ừ chay ngon đấy
này
về
chính sách trẻ em
trai chồng ngon đấy chứ trai mới vậy tôi
chưa rồi nhìn thấy xa lạ luôn cho ngon
được
ở hàng ghế đầu con chọn theo cửa hàng
ghế này được này
Ừ nhưng mà tôi cho mấy ông xem cái này
rồi nhìn cái nếu bắt chước được mà đúng
ạ như này Không vẫn chưa được này không
Tôi khẳng định với ông nhìn qua này cái
kiểu gì mấy ông có đủ kinh nghiệm để bắt
chước máy này rồi Nếu không có đủ kiến
thức để mình nhìn qua là à Cái này làm
như thế nào có nhiều phát tôi hiểu được
cái đoạn này bọn nó làm như nào mà làm
được
ở tầm mấy dồi kiến thức của Khi mà mình
đến cái ngưỡng lập trình viên và là biết
có thế thì nhìn vào bức cái trang nào
Bây giờ mình cũng gần như là đều biết
làm được có thể công nghệ mình không
giống nó như mình ốp về gọi là copy để
mà đổ dạng như giống kiểu Trung Quốc có
chuyên để sao chép là ăn cắp ý tưởng ấy
thì giai đoạn này thừa sức mình làm được
nghĩa nhìn ở đấy mình sinh ra được ra
đây vẫn làm được làm tốt
các em à Thôi làm đi cô đơn giản thôi về
nhôm còn chưa làm xong cái gì cả vãi
chưởng Có nhớ nhóm này có bạn cả hai bạn
cũng đều ổn mà bạn Minh Châu à những
chậu chứng minh Minh Châu thôi nhớ rồi
là bạn Dũng hệ ổn
cho đến bây giờ vẫn chưa làm gì cả mấy
ông đôi khi hay bị
Em hãy bị kiểu ở nghĩ nó máy móc quá làm
bị tốn thời gian có cho những cái thứ mà
xong rồi Công Thì mình vẫn chưa hoàn
thiện cái gì không nên như thế
một tuần thôi Chứ ngồi mò một cái công
nghệ thì tôi xem được trên mạng thấy hay
hay tôi muốn ốp về chàng Mình ốm mãi
không được tốn quá nhiều thời gian cho
nó
bạn này tạm cái chân hay này
Ừ
nhưng mà đừng có dùng đấy b nữa đậu xanh
tại sao bạn này phải dùng b
bổ sung dung Mua đồ nha
I Were Not In
Khi
bữa nay xử lý nhà đấy
tại sao phải xử lý kiểu rừng ra nhanh
nhỉ ở Sapa
see More lessons
Anh đang này sao phải xử lý dâm đào này
tôi không hiểu luôn á
để xem cốt cốt lại nhé Bạn muốn lấy cái
này
sửa lại nha nhìn lại sửa lại này
để tui vẫn chưa cốt bạn đấy vẫn chưa
biết cách cốt nhưng mà nhìn sợ lại nha
cho Nokia salad này đúng không Ok rồi
này
khi Xỏ cái gì selectrona
e ngại cao nhảy Ok xoay đi này Goodbye
Thôi bữa nay ok rồi này
anh em mặc định là and thereby cái này
mặc định rồi
rồi này
Em sắp này
không có đến hàm cao nó chưa hiểu đoạn
này ông ạ Ông gọi ra cái này làm gì nhỉ
Ông Nó dùng cái này ở chỗ nào đó ông
order vay theo này à à Tại sao phải làm
để ông đều vai thằng theo cái đồng mạng
không cần gì phải làm nhưng cái vừa rồi
đấy Sau đó thì ông ạ
em lấy ra anh như này được mà
Em bỏ cái sẽ lấy cái đi con chỉ Good bye
cho được ba như này luôn này rồi à
Ừ rồi Gì nhỉ thì thằng này sẽ là eli đi
đúng không thấy ông sẽ chỉ cần như này
thôi tiếp theo ông muốn lấy mỗi ai đi
thôi chúng sẽ alo nha lấy một cuộc đời
đi thôi
thế nhưng ai xa lạ
em yêu nhau nữa
Ê mày không nên tao sống 5.000 khó quá
em lấy
nhỉ
I were not in all directions tô còn chưa
dùng cái for erection này bao giờ luôn
Em không biết cái này ốm đấy lấy như này
kiểu gì
em kiểm tra xem có
hiểu kiểu như thế đúng không
phải như này Dạo này đoạn này ông Nếu mà
dùng lên chừng chip ông Trung là à
Ừ thì ông sẽ dùng cái khái niệm là không
Bích dao là không này
này
was down
anh như này xong
à our nữa
Owen kết hợp với dao hình như vẫn được
nhưng vẫn được đấy thử phát nhà để xem
chi Ban Nha
chị Xem truy vấn này biết Lê xuân này
ông đổi lại lesson đây đúng không
để tôi thử xem chị Vân cái á câu này nó
sẽ như thế nào tôi ra
Em mở cái
Ở mái đi Tôi thương vợ cái á nó lên xe
à à
em làm các cháu rồi à Họ sống khá khá
đập Abay rồi Thế có khi về gặp tao bây
giờ làm đi làm lại cũng mất công ấy nhỉ
có cái gọi là nó nhẹ hơn mà đỡ bị nặng
nữa
ở đây
có gì đấy Đừng gọi nữa
ờ ờ nhỉ
chịu không có bài đăng không có bài đăng
nào nha sẽ là Company này
a-prince
sao ý
Không Mày đang nghe
add ID bằng một trà sữa thế là sự thế DD
đề mà nói ra câu truy vấn chủ nhà
cho tôi biết không ạ
a
web môi giới này test à
I
always a phải dùng cho Wave nhưng mà
whey còn này thì sao
The men is in
thôi như thế dùng weather nghe được tôi
chưa bao giờ dùng cái phone này cơ Hay
phết
Ừ thôi nha tôi đổi lại cái này Thành Nhà
quê nó tin kiểu nhé Ừ bắt chước bạn ơi
nhé
id
ở những cái này nó sẽ bị sai của Vì ạ
Ừ đúng nhỉ Lại làm này bạn lại phải chắc
cốp là là ừ đúng rồi là là
cô giáo viên này không nằm trong lớp nào
à
khác không được
ở iowa ở đây đúng không
Hà Nội chưa hiểu về đạn này bạn làm gì
lắm
không thuộc lớp nào
Ừ ok nhận thế cách đặt tên của bạn này
nó bị cái hàm này bạn phải Quick Shout
hiểu sao tôi lại lecithin cho anh ạ Nó
sẽ dễ hiểu hơn là xử thế và đặt tên cái
này cũng
ở đây đây đây cái bà tên nó như này bà
là phụ inch tơ 060 kể cái này bạn ấy bị
sai điểm nha đó là
à à
cái này mạnh này bị sai một điểm về cái
á chân này tôi mới để ý kỹ đó là các
chân nó sẽ chỉ thực hiện
Nếu mà bạn là tên như này thì ông chỉ ở
giống như là ác chân là sẽ làm tác động
cho toàn bộ in chapter gà thế sai về cái
về cái logic khi tạo hóa sinh với nhớ
Thế nhớ ai xin nó sẽ chỉ nó chỉ có một
hàm thôi và chỉ thực hiện một tính năng
thôi Chính xác là cái hàm là nó sẽ về ốp
cho ví dụ Action ghét
Inverter cửa nhà
có ai đúng kiểu nhà luôn này get in
touch with Lisa đúng kiểu nhà luôn nha
Cái số 10 hàm này sẽ là hàm dụ lại
mình tôi tôi nhớ cái hàm gì Nói chung là
tên hàm có muốn Trọng đấy Nó kiểu
Ừ tôi Thượng Hải tập ví dụ ở bắt chước
thằng level thì thường ai kiểu với những
cái này nó có thể gọi chót mà thường
nghe đặt tên nó hay đồng A đường này xử
lý này
em hãy hiểu xử lý Thì cái này nó sẽ sửa
lại đúng kệ này
đặt tên là handle ngay thôi để xử lý một
cái gì đó phía sau nhé Xong kiểu kiểu
như này
có thể gia sử gia sửa như thế nhá Đây
ạ Và nếu mà giờ xử là Ừ nếu thấy ông dễ
bảo nếu mà em làm như thế sẽ có quá
nhiều hơn xin đúng ạ thì mình sẽ phải
chia nhỏ ra lúc đấy mình ở bắt đầu chơi
nhỏ và sự tạo thư mục là liên quan đến
in Doctor này
sau đó gì vứt cái hạt cái này vào trong
đấy như thế này đấy
ý thì cái này sẽ là áp chân ghét with
sao
cho Action chọn như thế gian hạn Tại sao
của việc hạn chế là cậu mình để nó trong
tên thư mục ngày mình sẽ hiểu rồi nên là
mình sẽ hạn chế nhắc lại đến cái tên thư
mục nó sẽ chưa ác chân ghét vẹn ghét với
da lishen hoặc là cách cách đặt tên của
thằng leo nữa thì nó sẽ thường à là để
mấy cái thằng thằng đấy ở cuối nếu Để ý
kỹ họ sẽ dụng lớp à lớp cần cho lô
hàng riscontro xong ngồi có nhiều đặt
tên là đặt tên cái quét ở quấy này xong
rồi ta tên cảnh chót cũng để của Vân
Miss được hẹn là tên cuối và tương tự
thấy ác chân mình sẽ để xuống cuối đây
nó sẽ là ghét với Charlie sheen hai chân
tại như thế Ok chưa Em hãy cắt đặt tên
nó như thế hàm và đặt tên Hà thì đơn
giản chỉ để thay đồ được rồi để bắt
chước giống hình chóp Thực ra hàng ngày
vì sau mấy ông mới nhận ra Hải không
khác gì mà thằng chó cả do Tức là sao
nghĩa là nó cũng sẽ xử lý 11 thứ thôi
cũng là tên là nó cũng Tây là hết rồi
nhé và xử lý một thứ như này nhưng thằng
chót nó có thêm một cái đó là
nó hoàn toàn Khuê đầy vào kiu
cho thuê tuần nói qua mấy ông về cái kêu
rồi fieldvue music will rất là sao nghĩa
nó có thể chạy nền chạy nên lại xử lý
nghe nhiều lúc mà ông muốn có vài cái
chạy lên là sửa tự động gửi mail khách
hàng ạ Ông không cần phải khách hàng
Thay đổi đội chạy Xong rồi đấy mới được
cái kiểu đấy
ai thích thì mình sẽ đẩy vào kêu để nó
sẽ cậu chạy ngầm gần chợ thì xử lý nói
như thế Ok chứ
ê ê
anh ở trong nhóm này trông có vẻ ra cũng
đầy biết rồi Khánh ấm chân là tội thấy
hay rồi xin lỗi
I get morning Star
hôm nay là
cả ngày để trồng hoa cốt cũng được hoặc
cả để trong con phi cũng được vì
Atlas cái gì đó đầy đúng không
I listen led driver driver Hà Nội
Như này bản chất nó ra luôn à
ở đây Tôi ỉa à Bạn ơi đừng lo cho ta mà
chị Xuyến sinh chị nghe tôi không biết
bỏ qua không không chữa được
chưa động là 8 sửa chữa được vụ này à
trong nhà
e class
anh cũng là một cái à
anh cũng âm kẻ trường khác
ở nhà không đặt tên thêm chữ á chuyền
vàng thì nó không nên cưỡng thế đó Sao
gọi đến hơn flash driver này
bí quyết tay vào gọi đâu
thế này
I crashed
Festival viết code tạo khóa
là
khi bạn đang dùng là P8 thì đúng tôi
chưa động vào mấy chưa chưa chưa động
vào
tôi động rồi kéo nó tới 8 giờ chưa động
thôi
chung cái này bạn để tạo ngay rất ổn này
nhưng tôi đã bảo đấy Đó là mình nên xử
lý mình nên xử lý cái nhảy sang cái chỗ
khác chứ không phải xử lý ở ở bên là
ở chỗ ở bên controllo container này là
driver và cốt để lưu lại driver không ạ
sẽ không nên xử lý cơ thế
ok này
ừ ừ
ở đây ai đi này Ừ anh Switch thêm khóa
trong được Có vẻ chứ Tôi - đoạn này Dạo
này phải Return à reason nhé Nếu bạn
đang muốn cậu là làm chúng avi phải trả
vậy Xin giống như tôi tưởng dậy mấy ông
về vi tơn sắp xít và Return pos chứ
không phải kiểu outro một giống như cái
hồi đọc thôi dậy Iraq là ngay nhé chết
trở về cái này đứa nào cái sau nhìn vào
lại chửi thằng thầy chết Ờ
Ừ cái này không has made Ok Ok tượng 30
dùng Nếu mà dùng hàm tự sinh ra của pp
thì không nên mà dùng cái hát của thằng
live hỗ trợ có rồi mà dùng được rồi ok
bạn chất nó chuyên đồ à khuya bồ Nó kiểu
như này rồi ông không cần phải chỗ ghi
lại toàn bộ kiểu này ông lấy Android như
này cơ mà
ô Thưa ông chẳng cần làm ngay luôn này
nó sẽ chưa ra là virus này mới tận nhà
cô gái ra sự thế Sông truyền thẳng cái
này vào như này
Khi bữa nay
không Thì họ sẽ ghi thêm vào trong máy
có ai đi này nó làm ảnh mà
ở đây password này
ở nhà được ông truyền thuê Báo nhé xong
nhiều
lý xong hết rồi chuyền kiểu váy biết như
này không gọi
máy quét
khi chờ như tôi đã bảo ở tôi vẫn không
thích cái việc là chuyện với quét xanh
như này về mà xử lý xử lý request vẫn
nên nằm tập trung hết ở controller xong
rồi Bên này sẽ là không gọi web ở nhà mà
bên này sẽ gọi bên cát biến hoặc là mạng
nó là cái mảnh mình truyền sang để nó xử
lý thôi request nhưng xử lý hết ở
controller nên nhớ một điều như thế nhé
Không không nên xử lý quét theo cầu nhảy
sang bên này gọi Quét ngay Vì vì mấy cái
này chưa chắc là mình đã vay bếp là xử
thế
Vì mình chưa khai báo virus ở trong mày
như này đấy đấy có rất nhiều cái Vân nói
chung Vì sao không nên chuyển đi quét
sáng vào thẳng vào trong thế này mình
lên có những cái Je riêng để truyền vào
thay đã rơi riêng mà truyền hình ai như
những điều thế Ngoạ kiểu kiểu như này
lại kiểu kiểu Ngày Trở Lại
anh đấy hôm trước tôi có làm để môi cho
bé ông ấy ở chỗ là bây giờ tôi không bảo
mấy ông xưởng món gì cả mà tôi đang
review để đánh giá qua để mà Mấy ông
giúp vẫn là rút kinh nghiệm và và cốt
cái đoạn sau nó chuẩn hơn đừng có đập đi
xây lại không kịp để lập đi xe lạ một
cái gì cả về chưa
a Viber cái cái cái em hỏi cái driver
này
a Viber bạn đấy à Đang người lái xe mà
kệ đi
mà
đương nhiên vẫn cần phải cải thiện lên
một vài cái đúng không ạ
em ngồi chém gió một tí gần hết ra rồi
a wifi ok rồi này nhờ nhóm mày không cho
tôi chữa nhìn này có vẻ giống cái hôm
trước tôi chưa có vẻ ổn hơn đấy Cái cái
nết này ta này tên lấy thêm sốt nêm này
Ok hay lấy tay lên da Tôi hơi khó chịu
Cái này phải như này nó vui hơn ok
Ừ nhưng mà tại sao bạn này lấy cái thai
đêm bằng hai này nhỉ em chưa hiểu lắm
Thôi kệ vậy
mà cái này ông có thể dùng cái mát đi
như bạn vừa nãy bạn ấy làm thứ nhất là
cái đoạn ta này đúng không Thế ghi cậu
ngay tại Open thằng luôn được ngay kết
hợp được à À cái này bikini bikini thì
không cho mát được
được nhé
Ông chủ nhà
quen được ok ok
mắt Christmas
a mắt nêm
à
a
Beer control your bills cũng chưa làm gì
cả
Ừ ok đoạn mấy cái đoạn này cha vẫn chỉ
mức tương đối như thế chưa thêm vì mấy
nghiệp hơn rồi
anh không Bạn này bảo bị nhầm rồi Cái
Future mình mình đặt tên nó sẽ là như
thế này
ở
những cái ví dụ update này update này từ
mạng
a little Light
ông ngoại thích này thích thì tôi thường
hay không có gì nhỉ à
3G Fast Connect
thường lại thêm tôi thương ai có những
kiểu như này còn gì em nha rồi chắc ngay
thôi Thì apdate kiểu nhà hai nó sẽ có
thường ví dụ lại áp áp Nhớ à nó thêm một
cái gì ở nhỏ Future là hẳn một tính năng
lớn còn cái này chữa một cái nhỏ thôi
Chị sẽ khác nhé ờ
cho ví dụ là app Viettel
áo kiểu dạng Peter Perry đấy kiểu như
thế
Em tải ứng dụng thêm những câu wellait
cái gì đó vào trong cái gì mà trong kiểu
ví dụ bên admin
sau đó thì post cho Index chả nơi
thịt chó Nó là kiểu Nếu mà không muốn
viết tắt thì rõ ra cậu ngay là thêm một
tính năng gì đó nó sẽ tính năng Ví dụ là
này ví dụ là điển hình posts như này Đức
thêm đoạn này hiểu được bởi vì về sau
ông làm sẽ là có rất nhiều đối tượng sử
dụng trang web của ông ông ấy biết làm
cụ thể ở trong cái nào còn nếu là sự ông
làm cả boss ở bên amin và cả bên mình
khách hàng nữa thì ông sẽ hiểu thêm
customer như này nữa mà sửa ông một ông
tách ra thành hai hai cái con nít hay
ông cụ chung lại kiểu thì ông sẽ thêm
thường mới thêm chủ em như này đấy tiếp
theo fake fake này thích nhanh một cái
gì đó và chị đầy đúng một cái con nít
cho một cái cái đoạn đấy thôi đừng có
gộp chung nhiều file nhiều dòng và thì
đấy không hoạt động thích đâu nó sẽ cái
khác thôi
tâm sự của ông sửa phải sửa rất nhiều
pha nó mới chạy thì phải thường ơi Đấy
thích này ra sửa đấy ví dụ là khi tôm có
vấn đề gì không chỉ là thích Twitter
ngay từ ông chỉ cần đặt tên ngắn gọn vậy
thôi Ông không cần phải thêm những cái
gì cả Bởi vì cái này còn chưa đẩy lên
rất nhanh và đấy sửa nhanh không cần
phải thêm những cái đoạn 2.5 sau một cái
gì cả
Wide format ông đôi khi ông chỉ cần đặt
tên đúng kiểu Nga reflect không cần bảo
thêm một cái gì cả rồi em giảm mà nó
không ảnh hưởng gì đến cốt Nếu mà nọ
thực sự ông Khi mà ghi format đúng nghĩa
ông trẻ có thay đổi do cách cài hay thay
đổi cái gì đó để đúng nghĩa là không ảnh
hưởng đến lôgic của cốt kiểu như thế ví
dụ ví dụ điển hình rượu ở trong nhóm này
cho ví dụ một cái đi trong pha này của
bạn đấy chắc ạ Đây thì cái phải này vào
dùm cái đi
tuyển vi format để cho kiểu toàn bộ gió
bằng bằng nhau không hề thay đổi một cái
tí gì là lôgic cốt thì tôi hoàn toàn này
tôi con nít đây này pho mát để làm thôi
Và thậm chí là tôi có thể cập nhật rất
nhiều file để free format toàn bộ tạo ra
đây không cần phải truyền thêm một cái
cậu chú thích hay một cái ý nghĩa gì cả
tiếp theo vi Porter là một cái là khó
mình cũng sẽ hỏi mình sẽ có ngày mà mình
sẽ gần như là cái vi poster gần như tôi
đã bảo nó là Cập nhật lại restored vào
đôi khi đổi tên file hay đổi tên biến gì
do đổi tên hàm cái gì đó thì mình nên
nên nói tóm gọn nó lại ra xử ra sự là
mình đổi từ việc à Đấy mình đổi từ việc
là Yêu
cầu xử lý bình thường xanh dùng lá sắc
hạ sẽ là xử lý số bom đăng lên bình
thường sẽ kiểu đổi Sáng Isaac thì ở sẽ
là phí vector bản chất là nó thể nó là
đồng nghĩa thêm chữ trên nghĩa là kiểu
thay đổi rồi mình mình chỉ cần là for
cái gì Tu cái gì thôi dù là kiểu form
như này xong rồi to bắt nhạc Cũng được
đấy xong rồi ở bên nào amin First
Class and update chọn thế đấy thì sẽ
hiểu là đổi từ form sáng ra kiểu Nha và
thay đổi đấy
các bạn viết thế nào kể các bạn đi
quan trọng gì
rất nhiều ông cậu dùng thế thôi ta đã
biết dùng đâu hoặc à Thì đấy thì đây là
lúc để mấy ông có thể tham được tham
khảo để học hỏi nếu mà cũng cũng đừng có
kiểu mình sửa hết cốt của mình để bắt
chước các bạn làm gì à
ông sẽ xảy ra con nít của bạn này đang
bị bảo bị ngược đó là cái này phải đẩy
vào đây và cái này đây và các đoạn này
nó thể ngắn hơn led
a section for this
a future đúng à
Ừ thế này mày ông nhớ rồi nhá cần tôi
thôi cứ đăng lên discord với mấy ông
Ừ cái cái gợi ý nhé
theo tưởng ai sẽ fit như này không ạ
ngày tôi đã viết tắt máy fit nó thành ra
như thế cơ à
a star auto tôi sẽ thương anh Hòa auto
cho Android
bóng
đá kẹo tự động những cậu tạo ra
I
read a
sắp chết chữ s
và đây sẽ là
bên trong bạn này có mít chồng ấy cũng
gọi cho việc để xem thử xem vậy cột đã
có cái gì import
mình làm gì
À valdez cái mấy cái wifi ở trong máy
quét này mà mình sẽ cho cáp để nó việc
quá Cái pha này của mình xử lý vấn đề gì
đó thôi mà ông ấy không dùng quýt hết
tình chồng vẫn buồn cười nha à
bộ làm xong mình sẽ nốt nhé Trời quá à
men is excellent
ở đây
a section ngày
ở ven
I read automattic sinh
are many sections
đẩy sang mua đồ xử lý khá ổn nhưng mà
nêu nó xong rồi gọi cho à
ở gan nếu mà ông muốn không Đỡ phải mất
công như ông sẽ chỉ cần gọi nha được anh
thằng đối tượng đấy Nếu không dùng đô
logic trong trong thằng này thì ông
không cần là đã kiểu kia đó em à
ở xa
a string ở có ví dụ cái này rất hay Tôi
rất nhiều lúc phải ví dụ như này để hiểu
được cả các cuộc cái thằng thằng cu li a
này nói cái gì mà mẹ chơi kiểu nha OK
Xong rồi trả về nhà được cái cách viết
ra ổn trừ cái câu này Xóa cái đi với
thằng này cậu ghi cậu đây tội đúng đi
chữ X xanh bổ nhà luôn này Này school
kia nha là anh xong rồi Như này ra ok
rồi xong rồi tôi một là dùng dấu ngay
hay tôi dùng kéo nha này ai sao nó sẽ ra
cậu nha ok Ổn đấy
Ừ rồi
Ừ ok ok iOne
a tiếp thematic
hình ảnh lệnh chuyển về cái này đúng
Ừ ok Đoạn này đoạn này cách tìm à Bởi vì
cái đoạn này ông thấy cái tham số chuyện
nó có dài bạn đấy có em tôi xuống lòng
nhỉ à
Ừ tôi khuyên ở mấy ông nên enter xuống
dòng hết như này
giờ nó còn hỗ trợ kiểu nó giống kiểu
mảng mình vẫn thể thêm dấu phẩy đêm cuối
này để làm gì vậy sao mình sẽ ví dụ Giả
sử về cho mình muốn thêm một cái gì đó
dụng xài mà đang bị dài tôi vẫn thường
hay cho xuống dòng thư này
nếu mà trong với 3 Master thì thì lại
không dấu phẩy của được nhá Với tôi ở
đây thì mình sẽ không có phải của nhà
được nhưng mà ở đây thì mình vẫn được
chấp nhận và về sau giả sử mình thêm cái
gì đó sự thay ngay cả ạ thì mình hoàn
toàn apk ngay để thêm hai ngày cho nó
cho được anh ra tiện cái kiểu như thế
A và đây cái thứ nhất thứ hai là ông có
thể thêm những cái kiểu bắt buộc kiểu dữ
liệu nó gì hoa cho defoe một cái gì đó
kìa Nghe nhưng mà một cái mục khi cái
photo tất cả những cái đẳng dưới đằng
sau này cũng phải cho nó Cái phô không
nó sẽ bị báo lỗi nếu không khéo bảo lỗi
cho anh ơi
à à
hôm nay tại Tây Ninh để một vài cái lưu
ý tiếp theo tiếp theo nữa đó là mấy ông
sẽ thấy là đôi khi mà về sau bị quá
nhiều cái cái á
Ừ cái tham số truyền vào như thế này
thực ạ thức ra nhiều nơi làm thì nó sẽ
hiểu nó sẽ tưởng như này
Ừ cái này nó Tức là sao đây ngay nó sẽ
biểu Biến toàn bộ những cái ông truyền
bao nhiêu vào nó sẽ là biến vòng mảnh
cái này và cái school gia này sẽ biến
thành như thế này school Đúng kiểu nhà
luôn đấy
ở Xuân schools nhân này được đấy
Ừ chiều kiểu nha nếu mà trong trường hợp
với sau đến chiều khoảng truyền và quá
nhiều tham số thực ra đây là một cách
nữa hai nửa giọt tôi Tôi chỉ nói qua mấy
ông tham khảo thôi Bởi vì tại sao nó dở
Bởi nó sẽ không đề xuất đầy đủ như này
đây thứ nhất thứ hai là ông sẽ không ép
được nó ra xử nó đúng kiểu dữ liệu như
thế này bắt buộc phải kiểu dữ liệu này
vào không cho nó cái tai phone nghe được
ai
Ừ nếu hiểu đứng nhưng mà ông vẫn thấy
virut ở đoạn dưới này cho ai đây nó bắt
buộc phải có cái gì đó vào cho nó cái fo
cũng được nhưng mà ông đấy là cái bất
tiện khi mà và ông phải truyền đấy Nói
chung nhà ông ông nhìn cái này nó trực
quan hơn nhưng nó sẽ nhược điểm về sau
có nhiều tham số truyền mở khóa với sau
Giả sử có một cái hàm truyền tận người
hàm sổ đó 13 mới tượng đó nó có em sẽ
cân nhắc việc là ông truyền lên cậu bé
nó thành cái mảnh nha Thế là xong về
chưa
các bạn sẽ lại playlist mình dạy web cơ
bản Đấy mình sẽ chạy lại từ đầu
khi làm web bán hàng có phải biết mấy
cái cốt như này không ạ
sẽ nhanh tiện hơn nhưng vẹo cái xong nhớ
mà thường ở bây giờ chẳng ai dùng level
để mà làm cái cái web đơn giản đã một
việc nếu mà Mấy ông muốn làm quen ông
già này không ôm một cái sống kiểu web
với CSS về ôm ốp vào xong Còn nếu mà ông
muốn tinh chỉnh Muốn làm những cái gì ở
phức tạp thì mới dùng những cái Facebook
xịn Nhưng kiểu như thế này nhưng mà rau
đúng là nó hỗ trợ
em hỗ trợ để làm nhanh mấy Vụ CIA có và
ông
Xin chào trên mạng rất nhiều Rủ tao đi
học ông muốn kiểu bán hàng không có bớt
như này hồ sơ đồ ghế thấp có Cần Giuộc
đi đầy luôn có rất nhiều cho mấy ông
điểm yếu ôm về một phát ngon lành luôn
Ok chứ mà nói Open xuống tất cả ông có
thể dùng nó mục đích gì tùy ông đấy
anh Ecopark làm việc trong bán hàng
thương mại điện tử đúng không kịp lót
không Block còn nhiều nữa lại rất nhiều
thả hồn ôm về chưa
anh nói chung là rất nhiều người đã làm
rồi ông đồng nghĩa là ông tham khảo cốt
người ta có rất nhiều ông ạ ạ
rồi đấy tôi tôm trước làm đúng kiểu đúng
theo hôm trước tao bảo này cho mình
không giống như bạn vừa nãy là bạn thấy
sẽ làm kiểu này bạn sẽ mất xứ hết toàn
bộ hiểu như hay xôi bạn ơi Trong này bạn
lại lôi từ trong bí quét ra đấy không
được không ạ phải làm như thế này khai
báo toàn bộ đây cách làm một cái ngay
sau đó thì xử lý các những thứ Ngay cách
làm một cái bởi vì tôn rất chuẩn rồi bạn
này ra cho nó Tôi thích nhà nữa cho
chồng đẹp rồi còn đâu khá chuẩn rồi
cái đoạn này thì nên nếu mà không như
tôi bảo nếu mà không dùng đô la gi trong
trường này thì mình có thể
khai báo sau thích ở nhà ai khai báo
hàng này hàm sau Tech vậy chứ nó sau này
sẽ không báo lỗi nữa và em tôi xuống
dòng Ok chứ
Anh nhớ nghỉ buổi hôm nay chắc à Cũng
tạm thời Thế
sau nhé
thì cứ bảo tôi mấy ông mấy ông phải chữa
dần dần phải chửi nhiều thì nó mới trội
lên trình đường nóng ạ
Ừ Ok nghỉ à
à à